[音楽]
[拍手]
大きな
拍手ありがとうございます
[拍手]
ありがとうございます私は
競技者そしてパフォーマーとして
活動しておりこちらにもご紹介いただき
ました通り
過去8回の全日本チャンピオンそして
過去7回の世界チャンピオンになったこと
があります
現役の
チャンピオンですそして
療養の競技者パフォーマーとして
活動するほか
普段はね平日は会社員をしていますで
社会人にも11年目になりまして
業種もですね実はヨーヨークは全然関係
ないお仕事をしていますただこういった
活動を認めていただいて今は会社に
スポンサーという形で
活動を
支援していただいてます
今日僕がねお話したのは
僕はずっと
仕事と
ヨーヨーこの2つの両立を
ずっとテーマに
ヨーヨーをやってきました今日は療養
パフォーマンスを
楽しんでいただく
他にもですね
仕事を
続けながら
好きなことをどんどんどんどん突き詰めて
続けるということのテーマに
少しお話しさせていただければと思います
お願いしますまずはですね最初にちょっと
競技の
容量についてご説明させてくださいそう
ですね
ヨーヨーってですねもう今見ていただいて
めちゃくちゃ昔のおもちゃと比べて進化し
ておりましてもうおもちゃの駅を越えて
世界中で楽しまれているスポーツになって
います
極人口は世界中でもう数十万か数百万人
とも実は言われておりまして
世界大会には約
数百人が約30カ国から1ドルに集まり
ましてその年の世界チャンピオンを
決めますそして競技のじゃないようどう
いうふうに表示するのっていうじゃない
ですかこれは
冒頭にお見せしたような音楽に合わせて
ヨーヨーを
演技するフリースタイル競技というものが
最も一般的ですじゃあ審査員は
演技された
演技に対して
得点をつけてご順位をつけています
フィギュアスケートがねちょっと近い感覚
かなと思いますそしてですね
競技の年齢層なんですけども実は
自由代から20代前半くらいが一番
メジャーで一番強い瞑想です
僕のように
会社にしながら
家庭も持ちながら30代で
世界大会の優勝の先生に加わるというのは
なかなか
正直
めちゃくちゃレアケースで
世界的にも
ほとんど正直いませんでなんでそう思った
んですけどやっぱり
学生と比べて
練習時間を
確保すること時間の確保というのが一番
やっぱりあのハードルになると思うんです
よね
実際僕も就職した
ばかりの頃はやっぱり時間が取れなかっ
たり結果が出なかったけどめちゃくちゃな
んですよ
でただそうなる中で1個これがお仕事をし
ながら好きなことでどんどんどんどん
突き進めて結果を出すための
答えの1個が
単位時間あたりの
価値を
向上することだと僕は思いますこれどう
いうことなんです少しご説明させて
ください
具体的にはいろんなやり方あると思うん
ですけども
例えば今日はね代表的な2つをご紹介し
たいと思いますまずは方法面の1個まずは
ですね
練習時間が今日あるとするとその
使える時間に対して
常に
目的
目標を持って
練習に取り組むことでした今日は1時間
使いたいと今日30分ですね今日30分
だけ使えるじゃあその限られた時間の中で
自分は何を達成したいのか何を目標をして
今からその応用に取り組むのかそれを常に
頭の中に入れて
練習に取り組むようになりましたそして
練習が終わったと思うじゃあ今日
目標を掲げたよこれに対して自分はどの
くらい近づけたのか
91時間前の自分と比べて1時間後の自分
が0.1mmもうまくなければいいんです
よ
そういった方法を常に頭に入れて練習に
臨むようになりましたそしてもう一つ意識
なりこれめちゃくちゃ当たり前のように
思うんですけどやっぱり今自分が用意でき
てるこの時間っていうのは
めちゃくちゃ実は貴重なものなんだなって
いうのを改めて
意識するようになりましたやっぱり仕事を
始めて自由になる時間っていうのは
学生時代に
比べてしょうがないそれは少なくてなる
ものだと僕は思ってますでそういう時間
っていうのは例えば睡眠に使ったりとか
友達では存在とかちょっとゲームしたいな
とかそういう時間だと思うんですけどそう
いったことに使われたはずの時間を家に
あえて自分は今要領に費やしたいと
余ってる時間が余ってるからあの練習する
んじゃないですあえて時間を捻出して
作り出して
僕が容量をしたいということを常に意識
申し上げました
でそういった悩みをいろいろ試行錯誤して
捉えた結果
結果結果的には
社会人選手になった時の方がなんた後の方
が
世界チャンピオンタイトルも日本
チャンピオンタイトルも
多く獲得することができましたそしてこう
いうことって
実は仕事の面でもすごくいいメーカー1個
あってやっぱり
練習用量をしてる時は100%この容量に
集中できるんですよということはこれね
仕事をしてる時は100%もう仕事に集中
できるので
結果的には両方のパフォーマンスを
上げることができたらできたんじゃないか
と思います
で今日僕が一番
皆さんの前でお話したかったのがこういう
限られた時間の中でも
好きなことをずっと続けるとか
突き詰めるとかっていうのは
容量以外の時もめちゃくちゃ僕は通じる
テーマなんじゃないかと思ってます今日
5千億をいただいている中には
学生の方もたくさんいらっしゃると思い
ますでもしかしたら今
自分がやってる好きなこととか
趣味とかあると思うんですよでもそれはで
も就職したらあんまり時間なくなって
楽しくなくなっちゃうのか楽しめなくなっ
ちゃうんじゃないかなという不安を
抱いている方はもしかしたらいらっしゃる
かもしれませんでも
僕は
結構そういう方にそしてあのちょっとだけ
お伝えしたいのはいやいやそうじゃなくて
工夫とかやり方次第ではもしかしたら今
まで以上に
好きなことをめちゃくちゃ
突き詰められる可能性なんで全然あるし
やっぱり僕はその30代になってから
ずっと戦いに
戦い続けてきた理由っていうのはこれ自分
より若い世代にそういうことを一つなんか
そしてもしてもらえたらいいか思って
ずっと戦ってきましたやっぱり世界
チャンピオンになったことが別に
結果ゴールじゃなくてなんかでそして
世界チャンピオンになりましたどうだ
すごいでしょじゃなくって
世界チャンピオンになった後に何するかは
僕はめちゃくちゃ重要だと思っててその一
つがやっぱり
好きなことを
続けるのって時には
難しいことあるかもしれないけどやり方
次第やっぱりできるしなんか自分が
好きなものを皆さん一つ一つこれから
ずっと大事にしていくことってすごい
面白いことだと思って
ぜひそれもお伝えしたかったです
ごちょこいただきありがとうございました
ラストもう一つだけ色々パフォーマンス
お店したいと思います
ラストは
紐と
ヨーヨーが離れる
オフストリングという
スタイル
ご覧いただこうと思いますこれが実は僕が
一番
得意な
スタイルでして
過去8階の全日本チャンピオンそして過去
7回中
6回の世界チャンピオンタイトルはこの
部門で
獲得したタイトルですやっぱりね自分が
一番得意なので
いきたいと思いますので最後よろしくお
願いします
ちょっとだけちょっとだけ準備のお時間に
なりますよろしくお願いします
[音楽]